3k squared plus 7k minus 2 plus 3 divided by 4k squared is the correct answer.
That's an amazing work if you got that correct. We know that 12 divided by 4
equals 3, and k to the 5th divided by k to the 3rd is k squared. 28 divided by 4
equals 7. And we're left with 1k when we compared k to the 4th, to k to the 3rd
we'll have one k left in our numerator. Next we'll have negative 2 for negative
8 divided by 4. And then the k cubed divided by k cubed equals 1, so we don't
have any variables here. And finally, we're left with 3 4th as a fraction and
then k squared in the denominator. We have more ks down here then in the
numerator. At these exponents are giving you trouble, it would be a great idea
to review. Try going back to properties of exponents and solving those problems.